well when Jesse smokes was still being
investigated by the police the New York
Times and other media outlets suggested
that it was a quote conspiracy theory to
suspect that his claims might not be
true the message was shut up and believe
it or else you're a bad person if not
clinically insane now as is so often the
case the few people who are willing to
think for themselves turned out to be
absolutely right and the press is
scrambling to explain how exactly did
that happen how could reporters who were
literally paid to be skeptical have
fallen for such an obvious lie it's not
an easy question to answer it's far
easier just to pretend the whole thing
never happened and that's what some are
doing Jeff Bezos is Washington Post for
example carries the almost amusingly
pompous slogan democracy dies in
darkness it's right on the masthead and
yet just yesterday the post did its best
to add to that darkness the newspaper
refused to run a single news story about
Jesse small that's hoax if you got your
news from the Washington Post you would
still believe that Smollett was attacked
by white racists for the crime of
opposing Donald Trump MSNBC did pretty
much the same thing once mullet was
arrested the channel did not even cover
the story in primetime other journalists
have decided that smart cannot be guilty
he simply can't be somebody must have
set him up probably from the racist
Chicago Police Department in other words
if the glove doesn't fit you must acquit
I think we need to see some of the
evidence I think it's very concerning
that all of these leaks came from the
Chicago Police Department so frankly all
we have is leaks from the Chicago Police
Department now what they said in this
press conference and with Jesse small
letting his team it said this police
department did in 2016
open lead through their union support
Donald Trump so to have a police
department that hasn't been as
cooperative as they have been this round
do not openly give information do openly
lie and Mis hold information and cases
and then to know that they are openly
have openly supported Donald Trump in
the 2016 election a lot of activists on
the ground are saying wait what's going
on here who do we believe out of these
two suspect people so was it a racist
conspiracy for the Chicago Police
Department that's a little far even for
a lot of people on cable news
so those people can see that yes perhaps
Jesse small its claims weren't entirely
factually true but so what they could
have been actual Trump supporters may
not have assaulted him on the street in
Chicago but they would have if they
could have if it is true didn't he in
fact attempt to paint magus supporters
as these racist and homophobic people I
think is true that yeah I won't but
Michelle I have to respectfully disagree
I think macro supporters are payment
themselves as that I mean when you look
at footage when you hear things they say
these are this is the honest to goodness
truth and we have to be bold and not to
call them black so this is the new
official story the one you're gonna be
hearing for a long time the one your
kids will be learning about in school
and it's this a specific hate crime may
not have happened in this case but hate
crimes overall are incredibly common and
the incidence of them is rising so the
lesson of Jesse Smollett isn't to be
more skeptical of hate crimes but to be
more credulous seenin wants that to be
your take away from the whole thing it
doesn't matter that it's Ankur slandered
and defamed almost half the country over
a lie there's a much more important
point here listen this is an America
where hate groups hate crimes are on the
rise the reality is there has been a
rise in hate crimes it has been a rise
of intolerance we know that hate crimes
are on the rise a lot of people don't
want to accept that they want this to be
trumped-up so the problem with what you
just heard is it's a crock it's totally
false
in fact it's provably untrue anyone who
says otherwise like people who just
heard is either intentionally misleading
you or doesn't understand the numbers
and that would include most journalists
type in the phrase hate crimes into
Google and you will see story after
story claiming that thousands of these
atrocities take place every year in our
country and the incidence of them is
rising a story in vice news yesterday
for example claimed that in 2017 there
were seven thousand 175 hate crimes in
America now reporters almost never do
their own statistical analysis for
stories like this they tend to be bad at
math in fact that's why they're
journalists in the first place and not
in private equity
making real money so instead reporters
take their numbers wholesale from
partisan activists who poses researchers
or from holy fraudulent organizations
like the Southern Poverty Law Center
these groups use moral panics to gin up
fundraising they get rich doing it so of
course they continue the problem is
there aren't that many hate crimes
occurring in this country it's just not
a very hateful place so they have to
make them up how do they do that they do
it and this is key by Counting
accusations as crimes an accusation is
not the same thing as a crime it's not
even close so if I accuse you of
committing armed robbery that does not
mean that robbery occurred you have to
be convicted of it and once you are I
can count what you did as a crime
otherwise it's just something that you
said it doesn't mean anything in real
life hate crimes are rare consider the
numbers from California it's by far our
biggest state nearly 40 million people
live in California its demographics have
changed dramatically in recent years
so if hate crimes were an epidemic you
would expect to see an awful lot of hate
crimes in California but you don't in
2017 in the state of California
convicted a total of 65 people for
committing hate crimes that's out of 39
point five million people in other words
far more people got face tattoos or died
while taking a shower than committed
hate crimes sixty-five hate crimes and
by the way that number has fallen not
risen in 1996 California recorded 87
hate crimes so that's the growing
epidemic that Don Lamanna and Chris
Cuomo we're just telling you about
they're lying it's a fraud hate hoaxes
by contrast are common the media spend a
lot of time denying that which is your
first tip that it's real
just this morning the New York Times are
in a headline that began hate crime
hoaxes are rare
rolling stone whose most famous story
ever was a hoax assures us that quote
false reports of hate crimes are
exceedingly rare all the rest of the
newsroom lemmings nod their heads in
agreement
don't believe your eyes this stuff never
happens but it does happen in fact it
happens regularly indeed the higher the
profile of the hate crime the more
likely it is to be fake those racist
messages the Air Force Academy you might
have read about the general who runs the
place gave an anguished response speech
it seemed sincere and it went viral but
the whole thing was fiction
the fake victims did it to themselves
how about those three University of
Albany students who were attacked by
white supremacists on a bus a few years
ago Hillary Clinton immediately weighed
in of course she was deeply outraged
this is America she said turns out that
three students were the dangerous ones
themselves they'd attacked a woman and
then invented the hoax to cover the
tracks threats to Jewish community
centers were a huge story in 2017 the
press suggested they were the work of
some deranged anti-semitic Trump
supporters assuming that's not redundant
in the view of the press once again
totally fake an Israeli teenager did it
and so on and on and on in the space of
a single month November 2016 there were
at least 13 well-publicized hate crimes
that turned out to be hoaxes 13 that was
also the month that Trump got elected
which tells you what's really going on
here
hate hoaxes are politically useful and
that's what people continue to stage
them we could go on about this and give
you many more examples starting with the
Covington story just last month there
are lots and lots of examples hate
hoaxes are so common that you could
write a whole book about them and people
have it's all public you want to look it
up spend an afternoon reading the
stories before they get scrubbed off the
internet it's an education you will
never believe CNN again trust me